Have you ever been having a conversation with the group and while maybe you were
interacting and talking to everybody,
you notice you always seem to be directing your attention at one particular
person and checking to see if you're getting a reaction from them.
Probably if you look around,
you will notice that everybody is doing the same thing,
directing most of their attention and looking for a reaction out of this one
person.
Have you ever tried to say something to the entire group,
but it seems like nothing you say even gets acknowledged by a single person.
Yet somehow when this person speaks up,
everyone stops and he has captivated their full attention.
Why is that?
This is because he is the anchor of the conversation.
His voice is strong,
charismatic,
and he's completely authentic.
He is viewed as being the one who provides the most value to everyone in the
interaction.
Therefore,
people are looking to him for input.
They hope to get is validation and when he speaks,
everyone listens.
Humans are amazing creatures.
We have the ability to learn amazingly quickly.
And one of the main reasons why is that we are incredibly good at learning
socially.
While it can be useful to learn socially in so many areas,
any idea if it gains enough steam can be accepted socially,
no matter how dumb are hypocritical.
This leads to a generation of men who've been led to believe that to be
attractive and to be someone who adds value to society,
you need looks,
status,
money or power.
Since this is what you need to be attractive and to have value,
you go to work to get the job,
to get the money,
to buy the things,
to look like the people in the magazine and then when you finally have it all,
it didn't work.
So the only conclusion you come to is that you need more,
you need to consume more.
And the cycle continues now because we learn socially.
People are constantly looking towards others to know how to think or act.
We live in an incredibly abstract world and nobody has any more information on
how to navigate it than anybody else.
Despite this fact,
we are always seeking certainty and whoever has the strongest,
most rock solid fixed interpretation of reality will have incredible influence
and will draw people into their world.
As humans,
we are biologically inclined to constantly be seeking out value.
Your brain is constantly zoning in on what has value to you and putting up
blinders to anything that doesn't have value.
This is why when you say something in a way that has little value to the group,
they won't even hear you.
It's not even that they're intentionally ignoring you,
but it literally doesn't even register in their brain.
If you take a second to think about this from an evolutionary perspective,
when we were living in caves and death was around every corner,
what do you think a woman would be more attracted to and who would add more
value?
The guy with the Chisel jaw line,
which obviously has so many uses out in the wild,
or would it be the guy that has a sort of rawness and authenticity to his
personality?
A strong leader who's decisive,
resourceful,
fearless,
and won't back down.
People are naturally attracted to what has value to them.
Value can be anything.
It could be someone who makes you laugh,
someone who gives you good emotions,
someone who gives you knowledge that could literally be anything.
So think back to that girl you lost or the one you never even got in the first
place.
Were you confident that you add value at the time?
If you were confident you add value,
how would you have acted?
You probably would have been conscious and present in the moment.
You wouldn't be filtering yourself and you'd be at ease,
secure with yourself.
If you weren't confident you had value.
You tend to be inside your head.
You micromanage what you say.
You seem contrived,
easily flustered and maybe worst of all you're constantly thinking,
how could I make this moment better?
You can never just be present.
If you weren't confident,
you add value.
You can be pretty sure the girl wasn't competent.
You add value either.
You can rationalize and come up with any excuses you want,
but the only reason the girl would leave is if she saw more value somewhere
else.
Try and be honest with yourself and think,
did your personality really convey that rawness and authenticity?
Now you have a few options from this point.
You can either continue to make excuses for why it happens.
Go into your cave and just play video games for the rest of your life.
You can take a page straight from a Hollywood movie chaser down and profess your
love or you could accept life isn't a movie and you can face reality as it is
that maybe you aren't that high value,
real,
authentic,
fearless guy you thought you were.
Now,
you can either be in resistance to that which is wishing that the reality in
front of you with some other way or you can sink into a deep acceptance of it.
It might hurt,
it might be devastating.
It might make you cry,
but you need to sit with reality instead of running away from it.
Ultimately,
these hard moments where you sit with the pain,
sit with the truth and don't shy away from it,
are going to be some of the most important moments in your life.
The difficult experiences you go through.
Strip back the layers of your personality and leave only the core essence of who
you are.
If you do this and you decide that you want to be that authentic,
charismatic person who captivates a room,
you can now start looking internally at what you can change.
So what can you do first?
You have to completely let that girl go.
Life is not a movie and you probably won't get her back,
and even if you do,
you probably spent a lot of time just waiting around.
What do you think the universe or God or Karma or whatever you want to call it,
rewards more sitting around and waiting or going out in dictating reality for
yourself.
You have to go out and meet women as much as you can.
If you don't let that girl go and move on,
you will begin to sink into what is called a scarcity mindset in your head.
There is no way any of the 7 billion other people on the planet could be a
special as one person.
Do you know how unlikely that is?
Remember how we talked about our brain constantly scanning for value.
When you can't go out and meet a lot of new women and don't have the ability to
be selective about who you date,
you will begin to project traits onto that one girl that don't really exist.
If you are coming from a scarcity mindset and this is the only person offering
value to you,
your brain will block out all the negative aspects of their personality and
focus in on only the good traits.
You can see this happening relationships all the time.
When the value is high,
we'll block out all the negative aspects,
how they treat you,
how they treat other people,
but once the value you once for Steve starts to fade,
all of a sudden it's like the blinders get removed and all you can see is the
negative.
When you do have new women in your life,
bring her into your reality,
she will be brought into mini mints,
reality and the one that provides the most value and gives her the best emotions
will be the ones she stays it.
It's like David data says in the way of the secure your main,
you have to be a man on your purpose.
The woman cannot be your purpose.
It is like she's at an amusement park.
She has the choice to go on any ride that she wants to.
Once you bring her into your reality and she sees the ride with all the twists
and turns,
she decides to come along for the ride.
But what do you fill?
Many men do the abandoned their purpose.
They say,
no.
I would rather sit here and talk with you.
Forget the ride.
The only reason she got on in the first place was for the thrill,
the unexpectedness and the excitement.
So what does a guy who offers a lot of value and how do you become one.